what's up guys welcome back to planet
coaster in this video as you might be
able to tell from the title I'm gonna
work on two things first I want to add a
playground in this empty spot over here
and second I want to devote the second
half of this video to the beginnings of
a Plaza with America around in the
middle though emphasis on the beginnings
because I was hoping to finish this
general area in this video but it's all
going pretty slowly so by the looks of
it it's still gonna take one two maybe
even three more videos to finish this
area there's gonna be a lot of detailing
so if you're into that kind of stuff
then enjoy all of these videos but do
keep in mind that it's still gonna take
quite a while though I do hope to move
into the rest of the park as quickly as
I can because obviously alpha 3 is
coming around and while I do hope to
finish this before alpha 3 so I do hope
that there is still enough time to
finish this park on the other hand I'm
also of course really looking forward to
alpha 3 because it's gonna be amazing
and I can't wait for it but that's very
off-topic to talk about the actual topic
of this video the little playground over
here there is a there's a reason why I
wanted to get the playground in and it's
not necessarily that I like playgrounds
though of course I really love them
myself it actually fits quite nicely
over here since this was an empty spot
and I wasn't really sure what to fill it
in with otherwise on the little planning
that I made I figured I would have the
car ride go over here but it seemed like
too big of a space and it seemed like a
space that could be used for something
that's more worthwhile than just making
an extra large car ride and I thought it
would be nice to have a playground in
here as an extra kind of scenery piece
it's not just going to be I know
functional as a playground and a nice
little place where kids could
hypothetically because it doesn't
actually work in the game of course play
around and go off the slide or take a
ride on the seesaw it's more or less a
piece of the scenery it's a good way to
get some extra wooden details in here
and some extra buildings almost without
having to play something that's gonna be
useless and something that a park
wouldn't want to spend their money
and overall it's just about the right
says it's just about the right size and
shape for a playground especially with
this nice circle and I thought yeah a
nice little brick sidewalk on the sides
of the playground where you can have
some benches and where the parents could
sit around and just watch their children
do whatever they want to do and yeah
that seemed like a pretty good planning
to go ahead with I do know that I like
to emphasize having an idea of what you
want to build before you had into it but
to be very honest I didn't even look for
any kind of reference material or any
inspiration for this playground it's
just based on one basic idea that I
wanted to have two wooden towers with
spiders on top of it and pretty much
just go from there
and see where it ends up so I wanted to
start off with the towers of course
because that's the only thing that I'm
more or less had in my mind and which I
knew how to make them and the approach
to making these things is quite a bit
different than what I would suggest you
do I wouldn't suggest you necessarily
copy the way that I'm building these
towers here it's more or less an
experiment to try to keep the camera as
still as I could it also helps to build
all of these pieces separately but the
most important reason why I was building
these pieces so separately and so close
to the camera here is to kind of show of
what they look like
and made sure that the camera doesn't
move too much that the time-lapse
doesn't become too quick and too
annoying to look at and yeah it's more
about the concept of this video than the
concept of the playground because quite
obviously it is a very simple playground
it's a type of playground which you
might see around quite a lot and I am
NOT the biggest playground master or not
whatsoever but um this just kind of
seemed like it good sort of standard
playground idea that could fit into the
theme of the park and could fit into
this somewhat small footprint as well
and also be somewhat easy to build so
I'm making the spire over here I wanted
to make it out of the wooden brackets
because it's the only
object that you can really make such a
very small spire out of these are
quartile wide building pieces so that's
why they all fit together very nicely
even though the sections are all made
separately but it also made making the
spires for it quite a bit harder because
not too many pieces are large enough to
make those very small spires but some
flags on top of it for an extra
decoration and between the two towers I
well wanted to make it quite tough for
the kids I mean they're gonna have to
exercise quite a bit on this playground
not get too fast so there's a bit of a
hanging sort of idea there which you see
in many playgrounds I always hated them
myself because it was kind of a hassle
to get to the other Tower but uh it's a
nice way to have the kids exercise a bit
just one more way to get as many of like
playing instruments as you can in the
towers of the playground the one
important thing that I wanted to get
into one of the towers is obviously a
slide but aside from that it's just
filling it in with a more or less
standard playground equipment that you
see around so there's obviously the the
bars that you need to hang on between
the two towers to get to the other side
there's some simple leathers that you
can climb if you're if you're a lazy kid
and you're like me and you just use the
letters even if there were like climbing
walls and ropes and things like that on
the side and I'll get to the more
climbing stuff in the future at this
point I just randomly figured I would
add some flowers and bushes and things
like that to the area because to be very
honest and you might be able to tell
this from many of the time lapses as
well I don't really have any particular
order in which I like to do things I
wouldn't even recommend that you should
have it it might make things a little
bit more organized but sometimes it's
just fun to go for whatever you want to
make and one thing that also kind of
played along over here is that these are
quite large and wide open pots and it
very quickly turns into this very large
sort of vast area of well Rock work of
the paths but nothing else and it's
quite empty and desolate so I wanted to
get all of these planters and all of
this foliage in around the
riah to provide some greenery to what
would otherwise be quite a boring place
that's why I wanted to get this in
before I went and finished the rest of
the playground just to get an idea of
what the playground would look like in
the photo environments of this area
that's why I wanted to finish that first
now I also wanted to take this
opportunity to add even more flowers
alongside the car ride which might seem
a little bit ridiculous but I still
think it's the it's one of the few ways
to add a lot of detailed scenery and an
interesting area to look at from the car
on itself because it's a pretty slow and
boring ride on its own to be honest and
you know getting life-sized scenery
large decorations isn't really the kind
of thing that a small park like this
would have so using the foliage as a
decoration as a almost garden kind of
yeah I kind of got in slash forests that
the car ride would go through seemed
like a nice thing to have though I
didn't want to decorate it with a couple
of different things as well to prevent
it from being too boring and predictable
so I did that little fence in there and
a small what's that called actually I
totally forgot the English word [ __ ]
anyway the small water thing whatever
English people call it and next I wanted
to get back to the playground because
all of that foliage is quite boring also
I did cut out quite a bit of an inked
foliage from this time lapse so you
won't see much of that in this video and
the next thing that I wanted to get into
the playground which is quite easily
buildable and it's also quite small so
it fits into the playground quite nice
is a seesaw which is quite a simple
thing I mean people are not going to be
able to use it so it doesn't really
matter that much but there was just that
one still open area of the playground
and in order to actually make it look
like a playground that you'd see in a
park I didn't want to have a couple of
like smaller things around the two
towers now for the big grand finale of
the played province Jesus I wanted to
add a slide to the tower on the left
here which is you know what we all came
for of obviously
it's very simple looking back maybe I
could have built the slide out of
different materials but I obviously
wanted this slide to be quite thin like
a real-life slide is as well and I
wanted to have a half ball kind of shape
to it like a real slide would have as
well and using the driftwood blanks
really seemed like the only material
that you could use for it since many of
the other objects are either not long
enough or they're very thick and very in
shapes that you commonly use for it so
it's out of the same materials as the
rest of the playground and also very
quickly there it's already a minute ago
but also very quickly there I added
another little climbing wall one of
those things that you have to grab and
climb your way up to the floor of the
towers now onto the second thing of this
video which is the plaza with the Feres
i'm the merry-go-round and this is a
pretty simple class I didn't really have
that much of a planning for it's the
only planning that I had was that I
wanted to get a small seating area in
with a trellis on top of it with some
foliage because that seems like a very
fun thing to mess around with though
that's only going to be in the next
episode the same goes for a restaurant
which I want to add alongside this plaza
as well it's quite far ahead from the
restaurant at the entrance so it seems
like a good place to add another
restaurant in so this can be a
restaurant but I'll add that in the next
episode as well but what I did want to
get into in this video is the general
decoration all of the foliage around
here and some of the rock work on the
side of the path as well as whatever I
wanted to get in and one quite big thing
for this plaza I'll be adding here
though it's one entirely be finished yet
is a store kind of like a Midway a
carnival game which is something that I
haven't really seen much before in
planet coaster and it's a nice cheap
addition to a park like this especially
for a park with the size of this having
Midway Games seems like a good way to
get some extra attractions in without
getting too expensive and obviously in
the game there aren't too many
attractions either so I wanted to start
off with a very simple almost shooting
gallery like game it's the the milk
bottle game which is basically milk
bottles being placed
two barrels and you have to throw them
over with balls that you get and that's
the kind of thing that I want to make
real quick here it's pretty simple and
I'll only really make a simple store
building for it with some of the barrels
and props that I'm going to have inside
and aside from that it's just one more
little experimentation with making
different wall pieces and different roof
pieces as you can see I wanted to use
the door over here as the top of the
roof since this is a pretty small
building and the bricks or the sandstone
parts that I used before to make the
roofs are quite large and very very
thick so it seemed like too thick of a
thing to make the roof for such a small
building out of and what's quite handy
about the doors is that they have a
different texture than much of the other
wood like if you were to use the
driftwood or the balconies to make the
roof with you get the same texture and
almost the exact same color as the posts
and the drift with that I would use
later on for the stucco and timber
decorations which doesn't really work
that well and since that door has a
slightly different and darker wooden
texture to it seemed like a good way to
get a wooden roof onto this building and
as you can see it's kind of very simply
made just one sort of desk in the
Front's where people are gonna have to
stay behind then the rest of the area is
pretty much where the employee stands
and hands out all this stuff and at the
back of the building is gonna be where
the barrels and the milk bottles are
gonna sit now if I skip ahead in the
time-lapse here you can see what it ends
up looking like there's the barrels at
the back some random balls out of
chimneys which don't really work that
well I still have to look into details
like I was pretty much just winging it
here and very small specific details and
figuring out stuff is what I usually do
off screen but I'll definitely show the
results of some of those things in later
episodes as well now I wanted to move on
a little bit here and go back to the car
ride where I still have that path
sticking out at the end of it which I
may very well remove at some point in
the future the only reason why that path
is actually still there is that if I
remove the path it's gonna remove a big
section of path along with it and I
didn't quite want to do that yet but
I'll figure that out as well
it's a little bit strange to have that
path go into the car ride at that point
but just to make the rest of the car
ride look Elizabeth more clean and
finished around the station wanted to
add a few fences borders and a bit of
foliage around the station as well it
kind of feels like the bathroom to me in
the sense that I'm really happy with how
the station of the car rides here now
even though it's such a very simple
building and it really doesn't have much
to it it just feels like a a building
with a nice nicely laid out a nice
simple composition to it that I'm quite
happy with how it turned out in the end
you don't really have to make everything
very complicated and I think this is a
good example of how even simple
buildings if you just fit them into
their scenery and function quite nicely
can actually work pretty well for this
building of course it is just the
station over car ride and I definitely
wouldn't want to make a restaurant with
the building this simple or small and it
really depends on whatever kind of
building you have toilet buildings and
stations like this are probably just
best kept very small and more as a way
to get an atmosphere into an area then
like establishing itself as the building
that you want to look at they're more
like support buildings that are kind of
meant to go along with the big buildings
in an area speaking of which the
restaurant on top of the hill on the
right side of this I was just about to
call it a ferris wheel again of this
merry-go-round is gonna be like the big
draw of this part of the park even
though this is a really small park and
it doesn't really have any expensive
buildings or anything like that I do
want to get into Rainey's a little bit
so you can obviously see the restaurant
sitting at the end of the path as you go
underneath the coaster and in that sense
the restaurant is going to be the most
important building and it's gonna draw
most of the attention in this area now
moving forward to the last thing that I
wanted to make which is perhaps also the
worst thing that I've made but um it's
something that I might want to get back
to in the future as well anyway I wanted
to cover up the yellow gates of the
entrance because if they look quite
awkward I am gonna be really happy in
the future once we connect
have some gate lives four different
gates for the entrances because it's a
pretty good looking gate but it doesn't
really fit in well with all of the
different themes that you might want to
get into and definitely for this kind of
Alpine theme it doesn't really work that
well to have a yellowy steel gates at
the front of an entrance or at the front
of a ride so I wanted to cover it up
with as many wooden details as I could
the only problem being is that as you
can see it has really big gates and it
takes a lot of words in a very bulky
shape to actually cover it up especially
with the gates being as toys it is and
the reason that it's quite annoying is
that this structure over here that's
meant to covered up is almost a nuisance
of its own it's a bit too large it
doesn't fit in as well with the style of
the rest of the park so I may definitely
experiment with it a bit and maybe
change its look but one thing that you
can't change about this is the size of
it since it just has to be this size in
order to actually cover up the gates and
it's quite annoying and I do wanna look
into it it's not my proudest thing it's
just that I wanted to cover up this
yellow gate if I do get something that
works quite well and I may just end up
doing it with this one in the end I
would like to just copy it around the
park and put it all over the different
yellow gates maybe change some small
things but it should be a good way to
get rid of those gates and have
something that fits into the scenery a
bit more anyway that's it for the
time-lapse part of today so thank you
guys for watching and I'll give it over
to my realtime partner it's not really
the best time of day as far as lighting
is concerned but the coaster is running
its little course and I don't want to
give away a POV before it's actually
finished because you know that's pretty
much how I do stuff but this is the
coaster at this point what's kind of
interesting about it though is someone
actually shot me a message and it was
meh no I can probably just say his name
I hope that's okay but um shot me a
message and said hey it's actually kind
of more like a zero-force coaster and I
looked at it and I was like yeah oops I
didn't actually know about that and turn
out that it really is more of a
zero-force coaster it has a slightly too
large elixirs especially with these
helixes
barely even touching the ground which is
more kind of like the very large and
stretched out layouts of the 0t valise
but actually does have the zero force
track profile which I didn't even know
before I didn't entirely recognize it so
that's kind of interesting I guess I'll
just call it a zero force from now on
but this is basically what it looks like
more or less is there a little station
for the car ride I might yet make some
cars for the car ride may also make some
small trains for the monorail still to
think about that I should also be able
to fit a station in somewhere along this
area because I didn't even fit a station
in for it yet because this is not really
finished I was hoping to finish this
part of the park by this episode but by
the looks of it it's still gonna take
and then one or two more episodes to
actually finish it I wanna have a
restaurant around here so that this is
you know nice and cut off and it doesn't
become an a very ugly transition because
I do not keep you know enough space over
here for the whatever Scandinavian theme
is gonna sit around here but yeah I do
wanna have some sort of border between
it and the German area is also supposed
to be the area that the park started
with a few decades ago something like
that so it's also the area where you
know I wanted to be able to stand on its
own as well and not transition into the
other areas too broadly which is
supposed to be added to the park a bit
later
so yeah I'll work on let's hopefully get
a restaurant into here hopefully if it's
some sort of monorail station into this
part of the park and yeah that's
basically why I still wanted to do now
to show off a couple of things that I've
done over here it's still very
unfinished I hope to get some trellises
with a bit of like seating area at this
point which should you know connect to
the restaurant on this side quite nicely
there's the very awkward gates which I'm
not really sure about if I want to keep
it this way let me actually put perhaps
to 200 FPS that might be a little bit
better here we go
see ya there's the arch over here which
is a bit strange I wanted to cover the
entire
yellow arch that you know comes with an
in-game ticket booth so this is a pretty
by the way but you know it's quite a
large thing and I wanted to cover the
entire thing so in the end especially
when you compare it to the scale of the
employee whose leg is actually currently
clipping through it that's not very good
might want to look at that but yeah it's
a pretty large building and I'm not
really sure how happy I am with it it is
a bit like breaking this area especially
with the little store over here being
quite close to it it's also vastly
unfinished by the way that it's maybe a
bit too large but I still might use it
throughout the park because I try to
avoid you know making those yellow
arches visible whenever I can since it
really breaks the immersion of the theme
what else is there that's the playground
of course I haven't even shown that off
to good
with a lot of bloom over here but yeah
it's a pretty simple playground as you
can see just some slides and some of
those climbing contraptions which
personally I never really liked so I
just took the stairs in the slide down
all day
a small seesaw over here and one of
these balancing things as well which was
basically all I could fit into this like
one of the important things that I did
want to do with the playground is that
obviously it's not a functional
playground so it isn't really based
around how good and fun it will be for
kids but the idea is mostly that you
know it's a piece of scenery it's
something to add to the scenery of this
area and that's why I'm quite happy with
how it turned out it might not be the
best playground but at least it gives a
bit of like wooden nice scenery in the
in this little area with those two
towers because the rest of this as you
can see it's a lot of just gardening a
lot of flowers and rockwork and just a
few small fences and things like that
beside the the car rail but most of
what's going on in this area is just
interaction between the coaster and the
car ride with a lot of foliage to fill
in the middle between it's to still make
it look a little bit more like it's a
Bavarian forest kind of idea with a lot
of flowers I do have to say maybe a bit
too few
a bit too many I should say and here's
how this thing does all of its helix is
it's quite a tall coaster that's one of
the things that
you know to kind of make me doubt if I
would really have to call it a forest
coast because for Scotia's I think or at
max ten meters tall and zero TVs the
custom ones can actually be quite large
even though there's still family
coasters so yeah this is quite a large
coaster for its time but I do think it
fits into the park quite nicely so
whether it's a force or a custom Tivoli
I think I'll call it a force anyway but
it's mostly about how it fits into the
park instead of being very focused on
being the most typical and standard
serie because I try to avoid making
off-the-shelf coasters which should
answer a few questions as well I still
got some questions about whether I would
want to do recreations of coasters or
make very typical off-the-shelf kosis
that you see cloned around a lot like
Batman at Six Flags or you know just the
zero figure eight could be an example or
the standard SLC model which SLC's is
certainly not even possible because
they're not in the game yet but
recreations and very off the shelf
models is something that I try to avoid
just because it's less creative you're
just really creating something and put
it in putting it into a park but I just
think it's more fun to kind of figure
out how you can you know really
specifically model something for a park
and kind of make the park around that
which is more fun and hopefully ends up
with more interesting and more
interacting coasters in the end anyway
that's it for today so thank you guys
for watching and I hope to see you guys
next time